drapeaux blancs sur leurs voitures ils
ont fui par leurs propres moyens ces
habitants de marioupol arrive enfin aux
apories jay
kay stockham n'y avait en gambardella
obstacle au nord - pas-de-calais
tous les marchés sont tous les magasins
détruits
et les envier j'espère que vous n'aurez
jamais
ici on attendait un nouveau convoi
humanitaire ce lundi après l'évacuation
réussite d'une centaine de personnes
sous l'égide de l'onu et de la croix
rouge mais en fin de journée il n'était
toujours pas arrivé le cren elle
rappelle que des centaines de civils
restent bloqués dans le gymnase opstal
et affirme que les russes ont recommencé
à bombarder les bâtiments où se cachent
des civils l'armée russe qui contrôlent
mario paul à l'exception du site
industriel déclare que près de la moitié
des réfugiés ont choisi de se rendre
vers les régions séparatistes du dombass
dans la ville les troupes russes et
séparatistes distribuer de l'aide
humanitaire devant les caméras il
resterait encore plus de cent mille
personnes dans mario paul qui en
comptait un demi million avant la guerre
au début il n'y avait pas de couloirs
humanitaires
on a essayé de partir les gens partaient
en voiture on leur tirer dessus je ne
peux pas dire exactement quelle
militaires tiraient mais j'ai vu de mes
yeux des voitures mitraillé avec des
gens et des enfants à l'intérieur
selon kiev plus de vingt mille personnes
auraient trouvé la mort à marioupol
depuis le début du siège début mars